hello and welcome to this video I am me
meto is my opponent okay I got one loss
against him on record that's not good so
early b6 it's a real line okay that
looks like somewhat weird moonflower
dish position takes you form it will it
will lead to some Google file type of
position that's taken shouldn't should
be too bad getting this the center here
it's not clear that b6 is essential your
home oh wow
hmm okay
yeah let's just go naija three I mean
maybe I could have taken but that
doesn't look too bad I wonder if Bishop
c4 and move him let's let's do this just
go full-scale development he cannot take
you to Bishop f7 and yeah looks
dangerous if he asks if he goes Bishop
e7 now then I'll take on d4 yeah it
looks okay getting that big center
with a six I can take a queen a four
wins apiece that's also no move Bishop
e7 looks yeah looks like the most
natural move um what now some queen bee
three your castle I think I'll just take
and i'm happy with mine I'm a big center
here just rookie one I guess one and now
that looks good knight c6 potus's idea
lucky night hmm well that's not bad d 5
9 a-5 Bishop d3 hmm but ok it's not it's
not clear that they have to do that yet
I think I can do this first I don't need
to play d5 right away and that looks ok
and Bishop g5 can also be a move wow wow
wee bit surprised that he can afford a
move like Bishop before looks like a I
mean it places the bishop right the
rukon III is ready to swing over to g3
or h3
there should be a strong attack and I
guess try to go on I dare 5 rupee 395
would be fantastic Queen f6 look f3
maybe you can give the Queen down but
cannot be enough
yeah probably something simple taking
taking 185 yeah that looks like but it
looks like rugby one may be threatening
Bishop f5
hmm
mmm Bishop f5
and don't see em don't see you win tix a
five tix point x is six Bishop takes I
have the check or kind of its close
and wow I don't see you in Bishop c4 you
can probably just take disappointing
somehow route b7 you can take the the
bishop once your phone
this is better for white but I thought
that there should be some kind of
decisive continuation and that i'm not
sure that this really wins time morning
probably doesn't win rookie six Queen
takes rupee a check if seven doesn't win
doesn't win either shoot 2543 has a bit
of a cheap trick until you can try okay
check oh I cannot take a selfie I have
to take you then check check check
check check don't want to draw a check
we have to check
yeah I don't think he can do much either
it's just just probably a draw check
check check check check okay I'm I
should've won that game of course around
here this is just winning somehow but I
didn't I didn't I didn't see it I
something didn't see it so II five wins
and yeah well but this this looked so
strong and so winds like d6 that's a
disaster threatening here but I can't
believe that this shouldn't win d 6 is
so when I didn't see the 6am after this
it still should win but it's not not
that easy Queen a4 is also good yeah
this is better for Wyatt but not doesn't
seem to win yeah I was a bit of a cheap
trick check check yeah I also think that
this is a win but here you have to be
precise age form it's done both given by
the comp yeah of course I just go to h 2
i just go here and then I run the pawn
up the board now that's a fair that's
very simple actually I can give this
check but I just get over here then then
some Queen away 7 that's probably a
pretty easy one
yeah he took more than some liberties in
the opening and then this is wacky
Bishop before more just just yeah
gifting me all that activity Kim yeah
these six is very strong he cannot take
with the Queen and the threat is simply
five with a devastating attack and
Bishop takes a five is also threatened
Bishop a five be a five queen bee three
check who now a draw it's not terrible
for the further for the first game in a
session but yet more was definitely
possible okay well thanks for watching